I've previously said Shauna that you
love to write messy characters yeah and
I was curious why you're attracted to
messy characters well I think I'm a
messy person and I grew up with one of
the messiest characters ever as a father
who was just so complicated and you know
on paper you would look at my father and
think oh my god
stay away like you got the short stick
in the father Department but when you
met him and you know you saw how warm
and charismatic and caring he was you
might start to change your your
perspective of him and so I think those
are the most fascinating characters
we're all over the place as human beings
and those are the characters I like
writing what about playing them did you
feel that your characters in the film
were messy or I know Henry was a good
artist he may be messy but you know I do
think he really cared and that's that's
the great thing and let you say it yeah
he does these amazing drawings these
very explicit drawings and you know he's
a very unique guy I enjoy playing him a
lot I love math yeah I mean I love messy
characterizations I and my character is
the first to would be the first to admit
that it was a mess and that honesty that
is is root to me is enchanting and I'm
Mapei I'd love to fix messes and like
I'm OCD about cleaning up messes so I
thought Laura was very good at keeping a
lot of stuff together so that's you know
she seemed to be then getting them back
together and then she should follow
striving to at least yeah what was
enjoyable to watch okay I know you got
your MFA from UT Austin
how is your writing changed since those
college days I was a horrible writer I
mean a really truly horrible like
unreadable things I wrote back then and
I think that's one great thing about
writing is the more you do it the better
you get so you know when I when I teach
occasionally and that's the advice that
I give to all my screenwriting students
just keep writing because you will get
better and I'm I'm looking forward to in
30 years when I write the most
whole epic screenplay ever because I'm
gonna be that much better than what
about acting how do you feel that you've
evolved from last year I don't think
about that at all
I don't I I try to evolve as a human
being and try to attain as many skills
as I can I try to work on myself and
understanding my own foibles and
transgressions and ineptitude and and
III sure you know you try to
self-diagnose often so that you're good
at diagnosing your characters but I
don't know if I think about like if I
improved in acting I think I only
unknown ly as good as the writing and as
my in my scene partners I think I
certainly learned a lot from getting to
work on this film and getting to work
with the amazing cast and lakeview I
said you know as your screen partners
and some guy at the work of Veera and in
Creston everybody you know absolute
legends they force you to to bring your
game up them to match to match their
level and I think the only thing you're
thinking about as an actor is what's my
objective what am I supposed to convey
what's important to fulfill in this
characterization what I think yeah I
don't think you think about am I being a
good actor or am i doing a good job I
think you'll be doing a good job if you
figured out what the obstacles are and
what your objectives are and what are
the character traits that you were
trying to you know die I suppose that's
the way we think about it